foreign ministers from a group of
emerging economy Nations known as brics
are meeting in Cape Town Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa are
expected to discuss the expansion of the
block more than a dozen Nations have
expressed interest in joining the group
books Nations have positioned themselves
as an alternative to Western
geopolitical dominance well let's bring
in our correspondent femita Miller she
joins us now from Cape Town samita what
are you hearing about just how much
bigger bricks could get
well we've heard from leadership here at
the brixa this foreign Minister's brick
Summit that at least 19 countries have
expressed either formally or informally
interest in either joining the brics
grouping or even having involvement with
the brics development bank which really
is aimed at investing in the global
South in developing nations to boost
their economies and this is one of the
reasons that bricks is becoming
increasingly attractive to developing
nations because of the support it
imagines it would get from such a
grouping and of course an alternative to
the west and that's the kind of
messaging that is coming through
increasingly from this meeting that this
is a significant and growing alternative
that this really is about a global South
emerging in a more balanced way a
counterbalance to the existing
alignments globally and we'd heard from
the Indian foreign minister talking
about world rebalancing and also this a
world a multi-polar world and Bricks is
a symbol of change uh we'd also heard in
opening remarks from Russia's foreign
minister Sergey lavrov saying the same
kind of thing but also talking touching
on conflict saying that they needed a
global majority Nations uh have to seek
common solutions to conflict around the
world essentially we're hearing over and
over again from leadership here that
this really is about an alternative it's
about brexit's expansion in terms of
providing these type of nations with
solutions that come from the global
South rather than the traditional allies
of the EU and the United States femina
you mentioned an alternative to the West
this is all obviously happening at a
time when there are particular Global
tensions for one member how is Mr
lavrov's participation going over there
well South Africa specifically is in a
difficult position as chairman or chip
as cheering the brics uh Summit that's
coming up later this year and even this
meeting of foreign ministers because one
of the hot topics of course is uh if uh
Russian President Vladimir Putin does in
fact visit South Africa in August when
that leader Summit is meant to take
place South Africa is a signatory to the
Rome statute and this comes as the
international criminal court has a
warrant of arrest for Putin uh for
alleged war crimes South Africa is
obligated to arrest him should that
happen in the days leading up to this
particular meeting South Africa has
issued diplomatic immunity to all those
attending but it's also gone on to say
that's normal it's routine to issue that
immunity ahead of summits and meetings
such as this so it wouldn't uh it
wouldn't supersede that ICC warrant of
arrest so that really is one of the key
issues that's being discussed at this
meeting besides expansion but also
looking at foreign minister lavrov and
this is now his second trip to South
Africa this year alone this really is
about showing the West that Russia has
friends that it's welcomed in other
territories around the world and that
those friendships are deepening a
politically and economically bricks
alone represents the members of that
grouping represents a quarter of the
world's economic output so increasingly
it appears to be a grouping that can't
be ignored and won the United States is
paying attention to very interesting for
me to Miller there with all the latest
for us from that meeting in Cape Town
thank you familiar